my name is Bonacci Wadhwa and I'm  director of the Center for meteorite  studies at Arizona State University  I study meteorites because I want to  understand how and when our solar system  and planets were formed and meteorites  provide us with a way of looking back in  the past four and a half billion years  ago when our solar system was just  starting to form and when the planets  were just starting to form and so by  studying these materials and  laboratories on earth we can really get  a great handle on that meteorites really  provide a way of exploring places in our  solar system that are difficult to  explore even with spacecraft so they're  really a sample return a free sample  returned from many of these places in  our solar system